every time I think we've beaten him, he comes
back stronger, grodd's here
we have to handle those gorillas get
over that bridge
your way out of any pointers go for the
leg
Grodd's Army could be hear any second
Here, we, go.
Welcome Flash
hey everybody it's Charlie! a lot of you had
questions after the last episode we got
new footage let's break it down
oh my god this is going to be so crazy
so if you guys are new to the channel i
do flash videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's even
a new giveaway going on for a copy of
injustice 2 game
I'll explain the end of the video but
basically what you have here is the
flash family like a limited version of
the flash family there's still a couple
of speedsters that we don't have on the
show yet like jay garrick isn't here
helping them out but it's them versus
Grodd and his army the cool thing about
this is that there are a couple of times
in the comics that this actually feels
like the way back in 99 there was this
Martian Manhunter comic we're brot
tricks the other aides into a war with
central city the other more reasons time
was during the new 52 a lot of you're
familiar with King brought he has
limited Speed Force abilities which
isn't exactly what's going on the TV
show so i'll explain that in a second
because it was a pretty cool story but
you have Jesse quick and Wally's that
are now working as a team which is
awesome very sort of calling the shots
you have Harrison wells looking someone
up to that device that they use to
communicate with avatar
it looks like they might be trying to
counter garage psionic abilities that
he's controlling other people with like
we saw that shot of gypsy she definitely
looks like she's being by control so
Cisco is probably going to try and help
her when they find that big WTF twist oh
my god gypsy why are you helping them
what's going on this go looks like you
getting his ass handed to him here
there's like all these Valentine's Day
things hanging around maybe this is
their version of the Valentine's Day
episode like oh my god
gypsies coming back so maybe she tricks
in that's part of how God gets his army
/ but gypsy is a good character i do
think that they'll continue to user on
the show she's too cool for them to not
keep using so somehow they're going to
have to rescue her from garage control
and then you have the military coming in
I don't think this is general Eiling at
least it doesn't look like him but he's
a really big garage character so it's
clean see Brown was available they
probably got him that it might be one of
those Manu Bennett situations where
like they want to get Deathstroke on
arrow
they're totally happy to do have some
Manu Bennett is a series regular on
another TV show Shannara chronicles that
shoots in New Zealand the most of the
time he would be able to get store
arrow even if he wanted to and it's the
same thing with linda park now I know a
lot of you're like hey wait a minute
while he's going out with Jesse quick
that didn't happen in the comics he
needs to go out with linda park so that
thing about that is that the actress
that plays Linda Park is now a series
regular on shannara chronicles'
ironically the same shows that the new
Bennett is on so Deathstroke and Linda
Park are on the same show shooting in
New Zealand halfway across the world so
that's why you haven't seen them again
that recently and the actress that plays
patty spivot to a lot of you asked about
her she's also a series regular on a
show on tnt
so usually bringing people like that
back is just an availability question
like Mark Hamill for instance plans
guest appearances almost a year in
advance and even like when he came onto
the tricks through this past year it was
a very brief appearance because of its
star wars shooting schedule so the other
big thing about this the flashing
Atomics was only able to defeat King
garage at least during the new 52 the
Speed Force version of fraud by sucking
him into the Speed Force in trapping him
that's probably not gonna happen on this
TV show
there have been other earlier fights
with broad with non Speed Force Power
garage where he is able to defeat him
but a lot of times it's only with the
help of Solovar so a big part of the
reason episode was in flash refusing to
kill solovar we didn't feel the garage
did with him at the end of the episode
he probably just had a bunch of eight
carrying off and throw them in itself
but he did reveal that the reason that
he needed the flashes help in the first
place is because he was not powerful
enough to stop soul of our five himself
meaning that soul of our can be grown in
a fight so solovar is the key to this
next episode so let me know in the
comments how long do you think it's
going to be in this next episode before
they have the idea to get Solovar's
help before he enters the fight is
totally possible they could have some of
the resolution the flash family can
defeat really big buildings and grounds
kind of like a warm-up force avatar like
the flash family will have to work
together to defeat Savitar at the end of
the season but it's completely dependent
on their tactics their ability to work
at the team and varies ability to work
as a leader and coordinate their attack
so who is the worst about battle
planning and
coordinating with other speedsters Wally
West he literally just did that in this
last episode back sorry I had just
mentioned he had just become up on some
robbers and he just rushes right it hold
on I got this
he just goes in and takes them down so
what happened the last time the flash
rust in and try to take down garage he
got his ass handed to him so there might
be a couple of funny moments like that
where the flash family just has to
double down and come up with a different
plan that same thing happened in the
last episode when he was fighting Solovarr
you need to do something that you've
never done before use the reverse-flash
trick so a big part of fighting broad
effectively in this next episode isn't
learning a couple new tricks or at least
using tricks that you know about that
you've never tried before a lot of you
have also asked why doesn't garage as
mind control one of the speedsters
there's been a couple weird explanations
for this in the comics during the wally
west era when the ginger Wally West was
the main versions of flash in the red
costume
they said that his brain function too
quickly for garage control that was a
bit of a crazy explainer but we did see
that rod was able to telepathically
communicate with the flash we can still
give them really crazy vision but
they're not quite as susceptible to my
control is a normal people are or even
people like Cisco or gypsy just these
way more powerful than cisco and what
about the red lightning a lot of you
asked me about the red lightning in the
last episode like is this an error
what's going on with very part of that I
think is mostly just to differentiate
that visually it's not so much as she'd
think technically Barry is faster than
both of these versions of the flash
right now faster than Jesse quick and
faster than wally west now he's trying
to make Wally West faster than he is but
unless there's some giant dirt area is
still the fastest version of the flash
so technically a fairy was faster if
you're going by the visible spectrum and
berries Lightning would be a little bit
closer to blue like it would be a
brighter color not a dollar color like
red
so maybe they'll have a moment like that
would explain it on the TV show but
really I think it's just a visual thing
like they're not going exactly by the
comics there's always a few differences
between the TV show the comic the movies
even do the same thing to the other big
question that I got after the last
episode is why didn't garage just
mind-control Cisco's the first time
instead of engineering this big
situation with gypsy and that's mostly
because of the way he needed to convince
the other gorillas what was going on it
was all a bunch of trickery on his part
look the humans are invading they're
trying to hurt us we need to fight them
or us we're going to kill us
so Grodd can mind control a bunch of
other gorillas but he can't control
everybody can't mind control that whole
army so he needs them to believe that
the humans are at the red so that's the
whole reason why you couldn't just
mind-control cisco from the beginning
and just take them all over immediately
that gets back to the idea of soul of
ours the fact that there are good
Gorillaz so it as long as you can get
rid of garage and show the other
gorillas the easy evil they will stop
attacking central city because they look
at that army there is no way they're
going to be all them at the same time
that's probably the big twist of the
episode they can't defeat Grodd they
have to find a way to discredit him so
that the other gorillas stop on their
own but it's going to be crazy episode
you can definitely see they funneled a
lot of their budgets from this
two-parter into this part like this
crazy attack with the giant gorilla army
so the schedule because so much comic
book stuff happened this week and I need
to get through the schedule is going to
be a little bit different so a bunch of
you requested that I do agents of shield
so what I'm going to do next for my
video later tonight is it will be
infinity war in humans and agents of
shield that will post a couple hours and
then thursday i'll do my arrow video
with legends of tomorrow in the same
video just because there's so much stuff
going on because I got something
ragnarok there's new guardians of the
galaxy there's even more star wars in
infinity war that i'll try to get out on
friday so it's just going to be crazy
the next couple days and i don't want to
try to do more than two videos a day so
give away there's new round of the
injustice to give away i'm giving away a
copy of the game
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner
alan garcia please private message me on
the back into my channel so i can get
your contact details so New Avengers in
human shield posting a couple hours
while you wait for that you can click
here for my flash episode and you can
click here to learn all about this
avatar prophecy
thank you so much watching where you
wait to that you can click here for my
flash episode you can click here to
learn all about Wonder Woman Ares thank
you so much for watching what i thought
i'll see you guys in the next video!